it was so world is a cipher you already
know that hope oh I'm gonna teach you
how to get some waves at I do right
first I don't when do eyes when I was
about seven eight years old I'm
definitely an expert I just remember
becoming a really obsessed with my hair
I was when I first started getting into
like grooming myself and actually can
what people thought about what I look
like you know I got used to the
compliments I like that the compliments
from the ladies the do-rag is not
necessary when there's time to show the
waves off do-rag is magical when you
take it off that's when the magic
happens
and you get to show the wave though I'm
an expert so I don't need any man or
anything I just kind of look up please
I'm Alana straight like that pull back a
little bit strings back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
first you have to brush it here right
brush it here this is a Dayan brush it's
a really good brush because the bristles
are very compact and it's a lot of
bristles that that means that it gives
you a good brush then after you brush
your hair then you wash your hair this
is like a shampoo kind of thing but you
can use pretty much any soap you have
just kind of apply it to your hair where
your hair is really white you take the
brush of the can and you brush your
waves back into place because you put in
the soap in its gonna get all fuzzy and
messed up but you're gonna brush it
right back into place is gonna fall
right in line like a puzzle you gonna
start seeing your waves come in then you
take the grease this is 360 style this
is like a soft kind of beeswax kind of
grease when you rub it on your hand
it gets really shiny like and you see
the Charlotte you just take enough
grease mission you did the whole front
both sides in the back I like to split
my life my dome until about full parts
you got to make sure you get the side
start from the top make sure you get the
whole flight start from the top and
and then brush you brush brush brush I
used to say my first I brush my hair 100
times on each side how many times on the
side right hundred times on left 100
times in the front hundred times in the
back but then I got so into it I just
said I'm gonna brush my head and my hair
and to my own get tired and that's when
my waves really start coming in real
nice very shiny very silky while you
have the grease and you have this soap
still in your hair and you brushed your
arms as tight and your hands is damn
they had six packs from brushing so much
you have to put the do-rag on put the
do-rag on very tightly and only silky
you only could use a silky do right
there is a such thing as a fake doo rag
it's called poly polyester do-rags we do
not do what's bad about poly is you're
gonna get joked on by my friends we only
do silk shoutouts the Silk City
polyester do-rags is just bad it rubs me
the wrong way it doesn't make your wave
silky at all with the silk do-rag that's
what it does it makes you a very silky
you only know it's a silk when you have
different kind of thread on the middle
you know the piping is different colors
that's okay so you put your silky on
real tight you either get in a shower
wash the soap and everything out with
the do-rag on or you can just kind of
get a wet rag or run your head under the
faucet you get a wet rag to kind of
place it and use it as a sponge to call
it and get all the soap out because what
happens is when you keep the do-rag
going very tight and in place the grease
doesn't come out when it so comes it
comes out so what happens is you flush
all the soap out and increase remains
and all of the hot steamy water is gonna
is what's gonna make it really wavy and
curly waves is nothing but curls that's
laid down it's laying down because it is
so good you finish watching all the soap
out your hair with the do-rag on if you
have a blow dryer you could use a blow
dryer and kind of dry your hair and you
do it if you got time to spare you read
in the book that you studying are you
doing homework you could kind of just
let it dry by itself with an hour so you
could take the do-rag off and why that's
when the magic happens you have your
ways this is like a little cherry on top
you add some pink lotion I take a little
bit of grease on one palm take a little
pink lotion or another palm blend it
together that's my own blend it does
something magical for me I don't know if
we could do the same for you but I like
to do it hit the head off four times
brush to my all be tired again and put
the do-rag back on when it's dry man
work wonders once you take that do-rag
off I'll keep my do rag on in a car all
the way to the front of the red carpet
and then when it's time to take that
do-rag off I hit the red carpet you know
paparazzi is going crazy my eyebrows is
on fleek and we're just working and my
sideburns is looking nice everything is
rocking do you have it man it's a cypher
and I'm signing out this is how you tie
do-rag and this how you get ways her
from the best silk and sire
you